"J'vois pas pourquoi il y aurait eu un clash sur Norman
et il y aurait pas un clash sur Cyprien
le mongolien !"
"Moi j'traîne au Champs-Élysées j'suis VIP
toi tu te fait recalé...
Hein Cyprien, avec tes blagues de merde !"
Tu clash dès que quelqu'un met une video en ligne !
Laisse-moi deviner tu chercherais  pas des amis ?
J'hallucine tu oses dire Cyprien le mongolien ?
OK, très bien, rappelle moi ton prénom... "Sé-bas-tien"
Mais Bah tiens, tu dis avoir créé ta marque de vêtements
mais coller une feuille sur un T-shirt n'est pas suffisant !
Insulter les gens pour exister je sais c'est﻿ tentant.
Mais fais autre chose de ta vie ! Tu viens d'avoir 30 ans !
Ça y est ça me revient ta tête d'obèse moqueur !
On était ensemble au CP mais, t'étais déjà majeur !
Quand on recherche ton blaz dans Google Images...
...On apprend tout sur toi rien que sur la Première Page !
Tu t'dis rappeur mais ta carrière décolle pas d'un pouce
la seule scène que tu montes, c'est sur un bateau-mouche !
Retourne à l'école !
Tes vidéos on s'en tape !
T'écris pas une ligne sans faire une faute, D'OR-TO-GRAPHE !
Tu veux absolument me rencontrer ? (sérieux?)
Tu m'as donné rendez-vous sur les Champs-Élysées ?
Mais y'a que des touristes et des pick-pockets !
Tu fais parti des quels j'ai ma, petite idée en tête !
Retourne matter les dessins animés ! Cortex t'es qu'un minus !
Si ta vie est une ligne de bus pour toi c'est le terminus !
Pas la peine de m'répondre tellement ton niveau﻿ est minable !
Va clasher ma grand-mère, pour un niveau équitable !
T'as aucun talent et tu parles fort : tu veux te faire remarquer.
Tu sais que t'es officiellement le Magloire du rap Français ?
Sébastien désolé, je voulais pas te clasher.
Ma mère m'a toujours interdit de taper sur les handicapés.
*déclic puis détonation de fusil*
Sous titres par GhirMohcine , Abonne toi !
Ah oui, au fait
"Tu fais des possecast, moi j'vais faire des possecast, tu vas voir j'vais te montrer j'te mets un vent"
On dit PODCAST.